لكن لماذا لا تحصل اوكرانيا على اسلحه
بكامله فعاليتها من الولايات المتحده وما
هو الخط الاحمر الذي رسمته واشنطن في هذا
الخصوص حتى الان لم تتخذ واشنطن القرار
بشان توليد مقاتلات اف 16 وصواريخ
لاوكرانيا وفق تصريح رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه الامريكيه الجنرال مارك ميلي
الذي اوضح ان الموضوع قيد الدراسه حاليا
مجله
حذرت الدول الغربيه من تسليم كيف مقاتلات
اف 16 لانها ستصبح اهدافا سهله للصواريخ
والطائرات الروسيه في اوكرانيا ونقلت
المجله عن نائب رئيس القياده الالكترونيه
الامريكيه السابق تشارلي مور قوله انه
خلافا للمقاتلات السوفييتيه تتطلب اف 16
مطارات طويله المدارج وهذا سيجعلها اهدافا
سهله للضربات الروسيه التي ستضرب المطارات
فيها وانتقد وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
ديمتري كوليبا دوله في الناتو لم يذكر
اسمها وعدت ببدء تدريب طيارين اوكرانيين
على قياده مقاتلات اف 16 في يونيو الماضيه
لكنها لم تفعل بالنسبه لراجمات الصواريخ
المتحركه هاي مارس قدمت الولايات المتحده
لاوكرانيا صواريخا يصل مداها الى 80
كيلومترا ولا تزودها بصواريخ
التكتيكيه التي يصل مداها الى 300 كيلو
مترا في هذا السياق نقلت صحيفه وولسي
جورنال عن مصدر بالاداره الامريكيه رفضا
رفض الكشف عن هويته قوله ان سبب ذلك هو
الرغبه في التقليل من خطر توسيع نطاق
الحرب مع موسكو
ينضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره محمد
العلمي محمد الرئيس بايدن في
تصريحاته او مقابلته لشبكه سي ان ان بدا
مبررا لاعطاء اوكرانيا قنابل عنقوديه مع
حجم الاجماع الداخلي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حول تزويد اوكرانيا بهذا النوع
من الاسلحه
ليس هناك اجماع فدا والمفارقه ان اغلب
الاصوات المؤيده جاءت من مصدر نادر ما
يؤيد الرئيس بيضا في اي قرار يتخذ جاء من
الجمهوريين احد ابرز اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ من
الحزب الجمهوري قال ما معناه ان من حق
اوكرانيا ان تحصل على الاسلحه التي
تستخدمها روسيا بالفعل في حين جاءت اكثر
الانتقادات واشدها جاءت من اعضاء
ديمقراطيين من حزب الرئيس بايدن بسبب
تحفظهم على التداعيات الخطيره على
المدنيين لان هذه الذخيره تسقط على شكل
قنابل صغيره لا تنفجر كلها من الطلقه
الاولى وتبقى لسنين تعرض المدنيين لخطر
بطر اعضائهم او لقتلهم كما حدث لعقود
طويله في فيتنام مثلا لكن الحكومه
الامريكيه تدافع عن نفسها على اكثر من
صعيد تقول ان روسيا تستخدم هذه الاسلحه
بالفعل ومنذ بدايه الحرب بل هناك تسجيلات
لمتحدثين امريكيين في البيت الابيض
وللسفيره الامريكيه في الامم المتحده
تشيران الى ان استخدام روسيا لهذه الاسلحه
قد يرقى لجرائم حرب وهي الولايات المتحده
تقدم هذه الاسلحه ايضا تدافع واشنطن عن
هذا القرار بالقول كما جاء قبل قليل
الفداء هو ان هناك نقص في الذخيره والى ان
يتم انتاج الداخله التقليديه ان صح
التعبير
بالاعداد الضروريه سيتم وقف اعطاء هذه
الاسلحه لاوكرانيا
او مستشار عفوا مستشار الامن القومي
للرئيس ان هذا ما قصدته الرئيس بايدن
عندما قال بشكل مؤقت سيتم تزويد اوكرانيا
بقنابل عنقوديه
نعم بالفعل لكن لا تخفي واشنطن ايضا
الاشاده بالكفاءه
القتاليه لهذه الاسلحه لان الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني واجه بعض العثرات ويبدو ان
واشنطن تعتقد ان استخدام كياف لهذه
الاسلحه الفتاكه قد تساعد في وقف زحف
الدبابات الاوكرانيه وايضا ربما اخراج او
قتل الجنود الروس المتخندقين في المناطق
التي يحتلونها في شرق اوكرانيا محمد
العلمي مراسل جزيره من واشنطن شكرا لك